incertidumbre entre los ciudadanos marca
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en Colombia en realidad
me siento muy desconcertada me siento
muy triste y decepcionada de ese país
las dos opciones como presidente no me
gustan absolutamente no voy a votar
porque no voy a dejar de ejercer mi
derecho estas elecciones son
probablemente una de las más polarizadas
en la historia del país esto porque los
candidatos Gustavo Petro y Rodolfo
Hernández representan opciones
totalmente diferentes de lo que no dudan
en calificar será un cambio y aunque
prometen reformas radicales en un país
que padece de una creciente pobreza Un
aumento en los índices de violencia y
otros problemas en la ciudadanía también
crece la desconfianza hacia estas
figuras políticas eso no lo mantienen
tan confundido de que uno no sabe en
realidad qué hacer Sí porque el uno dice
una cosa el otro otra entonces uno se
confunde tanto que yo personalmente opté
por no votar
un descontento que podría haberse
reflejado en las urnas este domingo
según la registraduría nacional el
pasado 29 de mayo día de la primera
vuelta presidencial solo el
54,92% de los colombianos habilitados
para votar ejercieron su derecho
constitucional situando la extensión en
el 45,09%